[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ولد ضيفنا الدكتور خالد فهمي في
القاهره عام 65 لا لا درجه البكالوريوس في
الاقتصاد اولا ثم الماجستير في العلوم
السياسيه عام 88 من الجامعه الامريكيه في
القاهره ليلتحقها بجامعه اكثر ويتحصل منها
على درجه الدكتوراه عام
1993 تنقل بعد ذلك استاذا ومعلما في عدد
من الجامعات العالميه منها عمله في قسم
دراسات الشرق الادنى بجامعه بريستو وبعدها
قسم الدراسات الشرقيه والاسلاميه في جامعه
نيويورك ثم رئاسته لقسم التاريخ في
الجامعه الامريكيه في القاهره وبعدها
جامعه كامبريدج واخيرا استقراره استاذا في
جامعه تافيتس في الولايات المتحده حتى
يومنا هذا اكثر ما ينشغل في فهمه والتاريخ
الاجتماعي لمصر والشرق الاوسط وتشكل البنا
السياسيه والاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه ومفهوم
الهيمنه على الجسد وتفكيك واع ضبط
المؤسسات التي قامت بها الدوله الحديثه في
مصر وكذلك الطب والقانون والحداثه اضافه
لدراسته المعمقه وتتبعه الوثائق الرسميه
والروايات المكتوبه والتاريخ الشعبي
للمصريين المهمشين الذين كانوا يقاتلون من
اجل مشروع محمد علي باشا الف فهمي عددا من
الكتب ابرزها كل رجال الباشيه السعي
للعداله الشريعه والطب الشرعي في مصر
الحديثه وكتاب الجسد والحداثه الطب
والقانون في مصر الحديثه يعد فهم اليوم
واحدا من اهم المؤرخين المصريين والذي
اختط لنفسه مسارا مختلفا ومتميزا في قراءه
التاريخ وفاهمه مخالفا للمدرسه التقليديه
والسعيده سابحث معه في هذه الحلقه الاولى
كيف تشكلت لدي هذه الاهتمامات والاساسات
التي بنيت عليها على ان اتناول في الحلقه
الثانيه مشاريعه الفكريه وكتبه الهامه
التي احدثت ضجه كبيره
في العالم العربي الدكتور خالد فهمي
الاكاديمي والمؤرخ المصري ضيف المقابله في
الجزء الاول فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
يعني كل المؤرخ يبذل جهدا كبيرا وخالد
فهمي على وجه التحديد حينما اراد فهم
الدوله المصريه بذل جهدا مضاعفه فما بالك
في حالنا من المقابله ونحن نتتبع نؤرخ
للمؤرخ او نؤرخ لعمليه التاريخ كانت مسيره
شاقه حقيقه لكنها لكنها شيقه وممتعه حقيقه
وتساعد في فهم يعني انا اعتقد ان ما
انتجته من كتب ومن ابحاث يساعد في فهم شيء
في غايه الاهميه نعود للبدايه انت مواليد
منتصف الستينات في اي اسره ولد الدكتور
خالد
اسره متوسطه والدي
مستشار قانوني في مجلس الدوله وهو الشق
الاداري من الجهاز الاداري القانوني في
الدوله المصريه
وان تودب من مجلس الدوله في الستينات
للعمل مع الحكومه الليبيه في
وقت الملك سنوسي وبالتالي انا قضيت سنواتي
المبكره في ليبيا في ليبيا في ليبيا في
العاصمه في الاول في البيضه وبعدين
انتقلنا بعد الثوره ثوره الفاتح من سبتمبر
لتر يعني الفتره الاولى من حياه قضيتها في
ليبيا في ليبيا اول اربع سنوات من
التعليم المدرسي
في ليبيا اذا اسره متعلمه ميسوره الحال
نقول ميسوره الحال خلفيه علمانيه خلفيه
علمانيه بس متدينين محافظين
نمارس الطقوس هل يبدو هذا التاريخ خاصه
انه بعده 67 وهو هذا التاريخ جاء بعد ثوره
يوليو وبعدين اكتوبر 73 هل يبدو تبدو هذه
المرحله يعني مفتاحيه في فهم خالد فهمي
بشكل كبير
الحقيقه انا يعني ولدت في اسره غير مسيسه
يعني
مشتبكه مع الواقع على درايه بالمجريات
الامور ولكن
ما فيش حد في العيله سواء اسرتي الضيقه او
الكبيره مشتبك بشكل مباشر
مثلا صحفيين او ساسه او
انما طبعا مرتبطين بالاحداث
وبنعيشها واعتقد اننا من اوائل التي هي
جنازه عبد الناصر
1970 كان عمري ست سنين
فاكر يعني طشاش يعني الاسره كانت لها يعني
حتى وان كانت لا تنشغل او تشتغل في
السياسه لها ميل معين مع او ضد
يعني مصريين في ليبيا طبعا انا اتذكر يعني
من من
احاديث الوالد عن الشعور بالهزيمه بعد 67
كمصريين في المهجر كان وضع صعب بالنسبه
للدراسه الدراسه الاعتيادي دراسه في ليبيا
ولا في مصر في الاول في ليبيا في المدرسه
الابتدائيه في ليبيا ثم
المدرسه الانجليزيه مدرسه النصر وهي مدرسه
اللي بنقول عليها في مصر مدرسه لغات مدرسه
خاصه مدرسه خاصه
ندرس الانجليزيه يعني الدراسه بالعربي
ولكن بجانب اللغه العربيه بندرس اللغه
الانجليزيه من الحضانه من اول سنه وهذا
ايضا يعني ساهم في تشكيل خالد فهمي ايضا
هذا النوع من التعليم الخصوصيه في التعليم
الى حد ما لها اثرها طبعا
لانه انا اعتقد ان المدرسه في ليبيا كانت
مدرسه جيده فتاسست بشكل جيد في ليبيا ثم
مدرسه النصر في في مصر الجديده في القاهره
الجامعه الجامعه الامريكيه درست وكانت
دراسه على حساب الوالد الشخصي صحيح درست
الاقتصاد درست الاقتصاد لماذا انا حققت
درجه عاليه في الثانويه العامه وزي كل
المصريين كان اللي بياخد درجات عاليه كان
بيخش يا هندسه يا طب يا طب فانا كنت
المفروض اخش هندسه وبعدين قلت لا انا مش
عايز اخش هندسه انا عايز ادرس
يعني اقتصاد وعلوم سياسيه فدخلت جامعه
القاهره
واشتركت كمان في الجامعه الامريكيه وبعدين
تركت جامعه القاهره يعني ما حضرتش
كملت في الجامعه الامريكيه في الاقتصاد
وده كان بدايه سياسه الانفتاح الاقتصادي
مع عهد السابع 77 78 انا دخلت 81
فده كان في اوج سياسه الانفتاح الاقتصادي
كان في فرص عمل في البنوك الخاصه التي
بدات في
انفتاح في في سياسه الانتداب طبعا ايضا
التشكل في الجامعه الامريكيه يعني هي
مجتمع داخل المجتمع تختلف بطبيعه الحال عن
الجامعات الاخرى عن الاوضاع التي يعيش
المصريون في في الجامعات الاخرى
صحيح ولكن في رايي انجامعه الامريكيه هي
طبعا في قلب القاهره في ميدان التحرير
وانا كان حظي اني تتلمذت على ايدي اساتذه
مصريين يعني اهمهم
وكان حتى الامريكان يعني استاذه لي عزيزه
جدا على هي اللي اسست كانت تعشق مصر وتؤمن
بمصر وتؤمن بالمشروع القومي العربي وكان
تقوم بدراسه تاريخ النظام القضائي في في
مصر
حتى الامريكان
الى حد كبير طب انهيت الاقتصاد وبعدين
عملت ماجستير في العلوم السياسيه في في
الجامعه الامريكيه
وعلى يد الدكتوره
وكان موضوعها هو سياسه الانفتاح الاقتصادي
من خلال التشريعات التي فتحت الاقتصاد
وحررت الاقتصاد قانون التجاره الخارجيه
قانون العمله الاجنبيه ونشرنا نشرت
الرساله بالانجليزيه في الجامعه الامريكيه
الاقتصاد بعدين شويه علوم سياسيه بعدين
رحنا التاريخ في اوكسفورد بعد ما خلصت
الماجستير انتقلتي الى اقصف انتقلت الى
اوكسفورد على اساس ان انا هدرس
تاريخ اقتصادي كنت فاكر انه هيكون ده
تاريخ اقتصادي جزء من قسم التاريخ من قسم
الاقتصاد
فذهبت الى اوكسفورد على اساس ان انا بدرس
اقتصاد وفوجئت ان انا قبلت في قسم التاريخ
فانا يعني درست التاريخ ما كانتش مخطط لها
ايضا جاءت لظروف الدراسه وظروف القبول اه
انا كنت عاوز ادرس تجربه
الدوله المصريه الحديثه
واسباب
فشل تجربه محمد علي متى بدا هذا الانشغال
دكتور يعني انشغالك
بمحاوله فهم تاريخ الدوله المصريه وفهم
ايضا الاشكاليات التي نتجت عنها والمستمره
حتى اليوم لانه انت تشخص الازمه بان ازمه
ما زالت مستمره ازمه ما زالت مستمره وازمه
تاريخيه حتى في الهزيمه تصف ان الهزيمه ما
زالت هزيمه 67
اعتقد انها بدات من دراسه البكالوريوس
احنا كنا بندرس تاريخ مصر وتاريخ المنطقه
وعلاقه المنطقه بالغرب وعلاقه مصر بالغرب
وك نت بفكر ان انا لو درست الموضوع بشكل
تاريخي من اصول يعني بدات متى بدا الخلاف
او الصراع او التكالب الدول الخارجيه
الدول الاوروبيه على التجربه المصريه
الوليده بتاعه محمد علي فده كان ده كان
الفكر ان انا ادرس الموضوع تاريخيا على
اساس ان ده تاريخ اقتصاد
فبدات في في اوكسفورد على يد
الاستاذى كان دكتور راديو وهو استاذ له
ابحاث في تاريخ الاقتصادي المصري وكان له
دراسه رائده في الستينات عن تاريخ القطن
ومن خلال دراسه سلعه واحده هي سلعه القطن
تمكن من رسم صوره متكامله للاقتصاد المصري
وعلاقه مصر
بالغرب وهذا ما فعله خالد فهمي ايضا لاحقا
من خلال دراسه الجسد العقبه الحداثه
التفاصيل الصغيره والتي من خلالها يمكن
رسم صوره اكبر بعد اكسفورد انتقلت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بعد اوكسفورد
عدت الى مصر على على امل الحصول على وظيفه
في الجامعه المصريه او الجامعه الامريكيه
ولم اتمكن ثم
سنحت له فرصه ان احصل على منحه دراسيه في
جامعه ويزلين
منحه فولبرايت على اساس منحه تبادل ثقافي
والتعليمي لمده عام واحد وذهبت الى الغرب
المتوسط الميد وست في جامعه نبراسكا
اللينك في لينك النبل العسكري
قضيت هناك عام واحد وبعدها
تقدمت الى وظيفه وظيفه دائمه في جامعه
برنس وحصلت عليها ماذا تشكل في خالد فهمي
المؤرخ هنا في استاذ كباحث اهم شيء قمت به
هو التعرف على مكتبه جامعه مكتبه جامعه
من قبلها من قبل انا اثناء
دراستي في الجامعه الامريكيه كنت اعمل
كموظف في مكتبه الجامعه الامريكيه وده في
حقيقه الامر هو تاسيس الحقيقي
لانه هذا قبل الانترنت
كشاب مثلي يكتشف ان هناك كنز لا نهائي من
المعرفه وهناك مفاتيح لقراءه الكتب طبعا
العمل في المكتبه مكني من ادرك ان
العلم ممكن فهرسته ممكن تنظيمه وبالتالي
تمكن من مفاتيح هذا العلم هذا العلم
ومراحل كيف كيف يمكن للشخص الوصول لمعلومه
ما قبل جوجل قبل جوجل
خرب الناس سهل على الموضوع انا اكتشافي
لاهميه المكتبه نابع او يرجع الى دراستي
في البكالوريوس جامعه اعتقد انه
تقتني اكثر من سته مليون كتاب
عشرهم يعني حوالي 600 الف كتاب على منطقه
الشرق الاوسط في حين ان عدد طلاب الشرق
الاوسط
لا يفوق 50 طالب
قرابه 600 الف كتاب بالعربيه والعبريه
والتركيه قليل هذا كنز حقيقي كنز حقيقي
وبالتالي كل ما تحلم به من كتب بالعربيه
موجود في جامعه استمريت في متى كانت
العوده العوده لانه العوده مساله مختلفه
تمام العوده الجامعه الامريكيه 2010 اه
بعد لم اسعد بالعمل في جامعه
نخبويه وبارده قليله وبارده قسم دراسات
شرق الاوسط بها التي الذي كنت اعمل به
وقسم مشهور
بنزع الاستشراقيه هذا القسم هو الذي
ركز عليه ادوه سعيد عمله في كتابه الشهير
الاستشراق
انت في معقل المستشرق فانا في معقل
مستشرقين كان بيننا دلويس كان تقاعدها
بالفعل ولكن كان يحوم روحه كانت تحوم روحه
من اسوا المستشرق وكان مازال موجود يعني
كان تقاعد ولكن كان مازال له مكتب
فلم يعني اقله في العمل ولم
يعني لم انتج الا كتابي الاول اللي هو كل
رجال الباشا كان رساله الدكتوراه عملت على
اعداده للنشر هذا ما قمت به اثناء خمس
وانتقلت الى جامعه نيويورك جامعه نيويورك
كانت جامعه منفتحه وقسم دراسات شرق الاوسط
في في الجامعه كان قسم رائد ويقوم بابحاث
رائده الاجواء بارده قليل هنا اريد ان
ننتقل الاستوديو لطاوله الحوار والنص اللي
للحظه الفارقه على ما يبدو التي عدت بها
الى مصر في 2010 واصبحت رئيس القسم
التاريخ في الجامعه الامريكيه وقلت لاحقا
انك شعرت ان ثمت شيء ما سيحدث لم تتوقع
الثوره المصريه لم تتوقع لكن شعرت بان ثمه
شيء سيحدث في مصر طبعا كانت الانتخابات
ايضا الرئاسيه وانه مبارك ربما لن يترشح
وما الى ذلك لكنها عوده تزامرت مع انقلاب
كبير جرى في مصر سنبحث طوال حلقتين مرحبا
بك دكتور شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
لم يمنع وجود الدكتور خالد فهمي خارج مصر
من ان يكون ضمن شريحه تشكلت من اكاديمينا
ونقابيين وسياسيين مصريين اعتمد فيها
الحراك المتصاعد في البلاد منذ منتصف
العقد الاول من الالفيه
ففي ذلك الوقت اسست حركه كفايه التي طالبت
الرئيس السابق حسني مبارك بالتغيير بعد
ربع قرن من حكم البلاد منتقده اداء النظام
في مختلف الملفات داخليا وخارجيا
اخذت تلك الانتقادات تتصاعد ولا سيما مع
حاله الطوارئ التي حكم بها مبارك طيله
سنواته الثلاثين على راس السلطه مع منطوت
عليه من عشوائيه في التوقيف والاحتجاز الى
جانب مشروع التوريث الذي اصبحت كل
المؤشرات دليلا عليه بعد ان ظل طويلا محضى
كاهنات
تمت محطه اخرى شكلت حدثا مفصليا مهدا
للوصول الى لحظه يناير وهو الاضراب الذي
نفذ في السادس من ابريل عام 2008 في مدينه
المحله الكبرى قبل امتداده الى عدد من
المحافظات المصريه والذي تعود اليه تسميه
الحركه الشهيره
وكان تغول الشرطه وتعاملها العنيف مع
المواطنين ابان وجود الوزير حبيب العدلي
احد الاسباب التي اثارت دائره المصريين
بعد ان تكررت وقائع وفاه لمواطنين
محتجازين قيل انهم قضوا تحت التعذيب
ثم جاءت انتخابات مجلس الشعب المصري في
ديسمبر من عام 2010 لتكون القطره التي
افاضت الكاس وخصوصا مع ما لحق بها من
اتهامات بالتزوير لصالح مرشح الحزب الوطني
الحاكم حينئذ ولم يستغرق الامر سوى شهر
بعد انعقاد اولى جلسات البرلمان الوليد
لتندلع ثوره يناير التي ازاحت راس النظام
2010 شعرت بالالحاح شعرت برغبه ما للعوده
وقد تزامن هذا الشعور وهذه الرغبه وهذه
العوده مع حدث جلل شهدته مصر في عام 2011
لماذا الح عليك الشعور بالعوده او الرغبه
بالعوده في تلك الفتره
انا اعمل اصلا على مصر
والماده لاعمل من خلالها هي ماده وثائقيه
مستقاه من دار الوثائق القوميه بالقاهره
فاثناء كل دراسه عملي في جامعه نيويورك
كنت
اواظب على الذهاب الى مصر الوثائق والحصول
عليها والاطلاع عليها كلما سمحت للفرصه
بعد فتره طويله من العمل في نيويورك
وددت العوده بشكل نهائي الى مصر العمل على
الماده التي
اعمل عليها والتواجد في في محيطي وتعليم
مصريين وتدريس مصريين
وكنت اتحين الفرصه متى
صنعت لي الفرصه في مجموعه عوامل عوامل
اكاديميه عوامل شخصيه بلدك الاسهام ايضا
كنت يعني مللت وتعبت من الغربه من الغربه
والتردد بين مكانين لماذا لم نتوقع ثوره
على الاقل بهذا الشكل لانها حدث
جلل كبير ضخم
انا كنت اتوقع
حراك
فكري ثوره ثقافيه فنيه في مجال الادب او
في مجال المسرح مجال الموسيقى
من خلال متابعاتي ولكن لم اتوقع هذه
الفورة
الكبير طبعا كنت محظوظ انني موجود كنت
موجود
وشركت
واعتقد ان هذا كان اهم فتره في حياتي على
المستوى المهني على مستوى الشخصي على
مستوى النفسي على مستوى علاقاتي
المختلفه وصدقاتي كل يعني كل اصدقائي كل
معارفي كانوا معي واختي تتحدث عن اختك
التواب التوام فكنتم تشاركون بالتظاهرات
المليونيه تذهبون هنا وهناك كانه كان حدث
حدث للمصريين يعني الذين ينتظرونه طويلا
لحظه المصريين الذين كانوا يرغبون
بالتغيير بالاصلاح بتعديل الاوضاع اه انا
يعني انتمي الى مجموعه من الاصدقاء
[موسيقى]
يعني الذين شكلوني سياسيا ومعرفيا وهؤلاء
منخرطون بشكل باشكال مختلفه في المجال
العام
ولكن في النهايه نعتقد اننا مجموعه صغيره
كنا نعتقد ان يعني
[موسيقى]
يعني
لا يوجد اعداد كبيره ما فيش ناس كتير
بيشبهونا بالضبط فاكتشفت ان في ناس كتير
يشبهوك في مصر في العالم اكتشافنا ان احنا
كنا اقليه في في المحيط الضخم ده الكلمه
الشائعه كانت الناس جت الناس جت يعني كان
ده يعني انه كان متوقعين ان الناس تيجي بس
مش بالحجم ده كانت ليالي استثنائيه ايام
استثنائيه ايام وليالي شاركت بتغطيتها على
الاقل
لك توصيف لما جرى يعني لفتني حقيقه واود
ان ان نسب في فهمه تقول على طول
المليونيات في الشهور اللاحقه التي التي
استمرت لمده سنتين كنت اشعر وانا الذي
اعتبر نفسي متخصصا في تاريخ مصر وقارئا
ومطلعا كنت اشعر ان الحدث اكبر مني وكثيرا
ما كنت اشعر ان دوري هو محاوله الفهم
والتلقي وليس التنظير الحقيقه هذا موقف
يعني رصين ومتواضع لانه كان ثمه من مصدر
كثيره في مساله الثوره كنت كنت تعتقد ان
الحدث كبير ويحتاج الى مزيد من الفهم
بالنسبه لك كمؤرخ كاكاديمي كاستاذ جامعي
ما بالك بالاخرين الذين صنعوا هذا الحدث
الثوري سواء الشباب سواء الاخوان المسلمين
الاحزاب السياسيه الاخرى
لا الاحداث كانت متلاحقه ومتسارعه بشكل
كبير واظن انه
بالنسبه للناس كتير كان وطئه الحدث اكبر
بكثير من قدرتهم على تحمله وده شيء بيحصل
في كل الثورات
بس كان يعني اللي انا كنت منبهر بيه وفي
نفس الوقت خايف منه كنت منبهر بنشاط
الشباب
وحماسهم بشجاعتهم وبقدرتهم على طرح اسئله
جديده
وبقدرتهم على التحلل والتحرر من
رؤيه اجيال اصبق ولكن في نفس الوقت الشعور
ده بالظبط هو اللي كان ساعات بيخليني
اتوجس واقول واتشكك ايه اذا كان الطاقه
الشبابيه دي عندها ادراك بتاريخها وتاريخ
حتى النضال الشبابي والنضال الطلابي
السابق يعني احداث
1962 72 71
بدايه الحركه الطلابيه المصريه
احداث 68
الشباب دول ما عندهمش وعي بيها
وكانه كان في اصرار على عدم التواصل معها
من ناحيه طبعا عدم التواصل بيحرر الشخص بس
من ناحيه تانيه بحس انه لو الواحد مش مدرك
هو جاي منين بيبقى صعب عليه ان هو يتخيل
هو ماشي في انهي مساره ورايح فين ورايح
فين وبالتالي مش قادر يتخيل او يشكل
رؤيه
للمستقبل كنت بحس ان ده شيء مخيف
بس بالنسبه لي على المستوى الشخصي كنت
بنزل الشارع وبسمع وبشوف اشياء مدهشه
وبحس ان الواحد لازم يتواضع امامها وانه
يسكت وينصت ويستمع ويحاول يستوعب عشان
الادوات اللي عندنا الادوات الاكاديميه
للبحث
المجتمعي مش سعفانه اللي بنشوفه اكبر
واعمق وانه الادوات اللي ممكن ان احنا
ادوات العلوم السياسيه كنت بحس ان الادب
والشعر هو الاقرب لتلمس الواقع والشرحه بس
انا ولا اديب ولا شاعر فكنت بحس ان انا
وجدي
كباحث كمؤرخ اني استمع يعني كنت بنزل
ساعات وفي ناس ممكن تنتبه لوجوده مثلا
صحفي فييجي يسالني
فقول له انت بتسالني ازاي اسال يعني صانع
الحدث هو اللي جنبي مش انا انا لو عايز
تسالني اسالني كمواطن عادي انا بنزل ليه
بس ما تسالنيش كخبير او متخصص دكتور كانه
هناك نشوى ثوريه اكثر من ما يجب الامر
الثاني كان هناك انقطاع مع ما سبق صحيح
كانه هذان يعني الامرين هذين الامرين
عجلوا
بنهايه سريعه ربما اعتقد ده جزء من
من المشكله وطبعا الجزء الاكبر هو عدم
التنظيم يعني الثوره من ناحيه هي بتعمل
فورا بس قياده العمل الثوري محتاج تنظيم
ماذا عن التيارات السياسيه جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين كانت جماعه الاكبر موجوده
والتيارات السياسيه الاخرى ماذا ما كان
فهمها وادارتها وتعاملها مع المعطيات
اعتقد انه يعني قراءه الاخوان المسلمين
للكجماعه
للحدث كانت قراءه قصيره وقراءه منكفئه على
ذاتها كجماعه
قراءه قصيره على كافه القصايده
في الاقليميه او الدوليه او المصريه بس
انا في رايي ان المشكله الاكبر في في
بالنسبه لنا احنا
جماعه مصريه
كمجتمع مصري وكام مثقفين علمانيين في
تعاطينا مع
الجماعه جماعه الاخوان المسلمين وبكل
الطيار الاسلامي في رايي كان انه طول
السنوات دي من مثلا نقول من 1928 سنه
تاسيس جامعه الاخوان المسلمين واحنا في
حقيقه الامر لا نشتبك حقيقيا فكريا مع
الجماعه مع الجماعه يا جماعه طبعا تنظيم
تنظيم موارد والماليه وله التنظيم واداري
والهيكلي بس هو كمان له فكره
والفكر ده يجب الاشتباك معه بشكل جدي
وانما في رايي دي قوه جامعه الاخوان لانها
عندها ظهير شعبي لاسباب في ناس كتير
بتحاول تختزله في انه الزيت والسكر اه في
زيت والسكر بس في شيء اعمق والشيء الاعمق
ده يجب الاشتباك معاه احنا في رايي مثقفين
والحركه السياسيه المصريه العلمانيه كانت
بتستقوى بالدوله وبمؤسسات الدوله وبوزاره
الثقافه ووزاره الاعلام انما وان احنا
نعيد نشرك مؤلفات
رواد النهضه النهضه من طاعه حسين
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين والتيار الاسلامي
على اطلاعب ده مش ان هم مش مش مدركينه على
اطلاعب ده ورفضوه وعندهم على اختلافنا على
اختلافنا واحنا كجيل تاني وتالت ورابع
المفروض نبلور اليات للاشتباك
الفكري مع هذا التيار انا كنت رايي ان
الثوره عملت انفتاح غير مسبوق بين
المصريين مكونات المصريين السياسيه
والثقافيه وانه في امكانيه للحوار الجاد
وانما وصل الاخوان للحكم انا في رايي كان
ده شيء مضر بالنسبه لي انا لا اؤمن بافكار
الجماعه وكنت حاسس ان هي افكار فقيره وان
هم ما عندهمش حلول لمجتمع لمشاكل المجتمع
المصري ولكن في نفس الوقت كنت شايف ان ده
تحدي تاريخي لينا ان احنا نشتبك معاهم
تحديدا لان هم دلوقتي في السلطه طول
السنوات السابقه كانوا بيتضرعوا بان هم
مغبونين ومظلومين موقع المعارضه موقع
المعارضه وانه بيقولوا لنا طيب ادونا فرصه
ان احنا نحكم
فلكن رايه استلم طب لو اردت يعني استطلع
رايك في تشخيص دقيق لمكان من الخلق الخلل
الحقيقي لدى جماعه الاخوان المسلمين في
الفتره ما بين 2011 وحتى ما جرى في يوليو
2013 يعني ابرز خلينا نقول اوجه الخلل
الرئيسيه في تعامل الاخوان كتنظيم وكحسب
سياسي وكجماعه دينيه مع الثوره
فراي اهم اهم مشكله
انه الاخوان انا في رايي ان هم في مثلا
وبنتكلم على الانتخابات الرئاسيه هم كسبوا
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بس بفارق ضئيل جدا
يعني اقل من واحد في الميه ده كان يستلزم
منهم الادراك ان البلد منقسم
وانه الحنكه السياسيه تفرض عليهم ان هم
يمدوا جسور التعاون مع الاغيار مع
التيار المختلف خصوصا ان احنا مش عايشين
في وسط المحيط الهادي احنا عايشين في
منطقه صعبه جدا والمخاطر الاقتصاديه
والاقليميه مش سهله
لذلك ربما لم ينجح انا رايي انهم مسعوش
بدرجه كافيه وان هم عمقوا من تحالفهم مع
التيار السلفي على حساب المجتمع الاكبر
وتقوقعوا على ذاتهم
وطبعا المشاهد الشهيره لا اثرت فيه انا
كمصري قبل ما اكون مؤرخ ولا محلل ولا اننا
اما اشوف
المؤسسي المرشح لرياسه بيكلم مش المصريين
بيكلم الجماعه ووراه المرشد والمرشد
بيلقنوا والواحد بيتسائل طيب دلوقتي مكتب
الارشاد هو اللي بيحكم يعني انا مش ضد انه
يبقى في مكتب ارشاد يحكم بالمناسبه لو
احنا بنتكلم عن حزب اي حزب بيبقى في شخص
مرشح وفي مكنه الحزب بتشتغل في الخلفيه
انما انا لو بفترض ان انا مش مسلم ان انا
قبطي هل انا ممكن ان انا اخش جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين
يعني جماعه الاخوان المسلمين مش جماعه
مصريه هي جماعه اسلاميه ده يعني مكمن
الخطر فيها طيب لو اردنا ايضا ننتقل
للتيارات الاخرى العلمانيه والليبراليه
التي كانت الطرف الاخر في الثوره المصريه
ما تشخيصك لمكان من الخلل الاساسيه او
اوجه القصور في تعاملها مع الثوره بما بما
جرت عليه برضو يعني من ناحيه ان هي
ما دخلتش
غمار
[موسيقى]
التحدي
الفكري العميق من الاشتباك الفكري مع هذا
التيار طبعا ده كان صعب في في ظل الاجواء
الثوريه
والاحتماء
بالدوله تحديدا بالجيش يعني انا عندي
وقائع كثيره ممكن احكيها عن
ازاي انه مثلا حتى في دار الوثائق القوميه
انهم يطلبوا من الجيش انه يخش عشان يحمي
دار الوثائق القوميه من الطياره الاخواني
يعني الدبابه هتحميني ازاي الجيش هيحميني
ازاي من المخاطر اللي انا شايفها في جامعه
الاخوان المسلمين
شيء الشيء التاني هو عدم
الاطمئنان للشارع عدم تجذير التجربه دي
عدم بناء تحالفات مع
الحركه الطلابيه مع الحركه العماليه عدم
بناء يعني التحرير دي كانت فرصه ذهبيه
لبناء
حركه والتاريخ المصري خير دليل على كده
التاريخ المصري هو حزب الوفد اللي هو كان
اهم وقعدته حزب قبل الثوره بدا ازاي وبدا
بحركه شعبيه
بتلم توقيعات قبل الانترنت وقبل الفيسبوك
وقبل التويتر والناس بتنزل بتمشي تلم
توقيعات لماذا برايك دكتور لم ينشا حزب
احنا نقول وطني للكل وافترض وطني
الليبراليا علمانيا في تلك الفتره مستثمرا
الانفتاح الكبير الساحات المفتوحه الفوره
الشعبيه الكبيره لم تبلور حزبا او تيارا
مصريا بخلفيه علمانيه او ليبراليه كان
لدينا الاخوان كان لدينا الجيش المصري
مقابل انا ببص لده برضو بشكل تاريخي بقول
انه
بقشفق علينا احنا الاخوان
والطيارات الاخرى من التجريف اللي حصل
للسياسه انا مش بس بتكلم على التجريف يعني
القبض على الناس والزج بيهم في السجون في
الخمسين ستين سبعين سنه اللي فاتوا
بس انعدام المهارات السياسيه البسيطه
عندنا فكر وعندنا توجهات بس في مهارات
بسيطه اللي هو اعمل قايمه الم يعني
المهارات التنظيميه في التعامل مع الناس
في الشارع احنا امتى كنا بنتلاقى مع الناس
في الشارع ما عندناش الطرف الاقوى والثالث
الرئيس اللي هو الجيش المصري المجلس
العسكري هل كان مدركا ادراكا عميقا لكل
مجريات الاحداث وكان يعني يسير بها الى
الى نتائج متوخه ومنتظره نعم ايضا كان
خاضع للتفاعل والاندهاش والصدمه اعتقد انه
هو كان خاضع وما زال خاضع للاندهاش
والصدمه الحدث اكبر من كل الناس انما اللي
بيفرق الجيش عن غيره اولا الجيش مؤسسه
الشعب والشارع ده مش مؤسسه
والاخوان طلع اكتشفنا ان هو مؤسسه اضعف
بكتير من قدرتها على التاقلم مما كنا
نتخيل مما كنا نتخيل الجيش مؤسسه ومؤسسه
قويه ده من ناحيه والجيش من ناحيه تانيه
مدرك تماما مش انا في قراءتي انه ما عندوش
قراءه دقيقه للواقع المصري ولا للشعب
المصري ولكن عنده قراءه دقيقه جدا لمصالحه
وده شيء يعني
مفهوم ووارد يعني وشيء جيد يعني المؤسسه
تعرف مؤسسه تعرف ماذا تريد هل ما تريد
يقبله الناس يريده الناس فيه فائده للدوله
او لا ده سؤال اخر سؤال انما الجيش كمؤسسه
مصريه
وطنيه عارفه مصلحتها وعارفه اهتماماتها
الاحداث في رايي كانت اقوى واعتى منها في
الاول انما عرفت تتدارك
الوضع وتدرك انه احنا ايه اهدافنا ايه ما
بدانا
والفكره بتاعه
الخلاف اللي كان موجود على التواريث
والتخلص من جمال مبارك
عرفوا يعملوه
وقطاحوا براس النظام بس
في نفس الوقت كان محاوله لجم هذا الحراك
الشعبي وده موجود مش من الجيش ده هو موجود
من 52 يعني في جينات الدوله المصريه
الحديثه لو قلنا هو التخوف من الناس يعني
زي ما بنقول احنا انه ماساتنا اما عرفنا
نعمل او اما حصل ثوره في 52
وتاسست جمهوريه المشكله كانت في الجمهوريه
دي ازاي ان احنا نعزل الجمهور منها فهي
جمهوريه بلا جمهور بلا جمهور يعني ملكيه
جديده بشكل اخر
ذهبت في مسارات مشابهه
ربما حتى اسوا فده طبعا لانه لانه
الملكيات معروف حدود حدود العمل فيها
والتسلسل وتحديدا تسليم السلطه الملكيه
وراثيه الجمهوريات العربيه غير المساله
تايحه شويه فماسات الجمهوريات العربيه ان
هي
جمهوريات مبنيه على فكره شعبوي بس الشعب
مش موجود فيها وده معادله صعبه جدا
لتحقيقها وانا كدارس لتاريخ مصر في
الستينات الخمسينات والستينات بنشوف ان
عبد الناصر على قد ما هو كان محبوب
وشعبي وعنده قابليه هو مش مطمن للشعب
مش مطمن للشعب بمعنى انه مش مطمن انه
يتشعب ينظم نفسه في نقابات او في تكتلات
او في جمعيات فكل التنظيمات اللي كانت
موجوده في مصر في الفتره اللي بنقول عليها
الفتره الليبراليه
جغرفه الجامعات النقابات
الاحزاب الصحافه
وبالتالي اما نوصل لسنه 2011
مش مستغرب ان الناس ما عندهاش المهارات
اللي تمكنها من بناء تحالفات
بعد ان ذهبت سكره الايام الثمانيه عشر من
الفعل الثوري في مصر عام 2011 بما احدثه
من زلزال اقليمي وعالمي جاءت فكره تدوين
احداث الثوره فتشكلت لجنه لتوثيقها واسندت
رئاستها الى الدكتور خالد فهمي حمل الدار
الوثائق القوميه على عاتقها تنفيذ الخطوه
وكانت الوعاء الذي ستصب فيه اللجنه عملها
عدا عن تقديمها كلما من شانه تذليل عمل
اعضاء اللجنه والباحثين تحت مظلتها وفي
تصور اولي كان المشروع يهدف الى جمع
شهادات مسجله من متظاهرين انخرطوا في
النضال من اجل اسقاط مبارك وهي مهمه صعبه
بالنظر الى وجود ملايين من شاركوا في
الثوره او ايدوها على الاقل
لم تكن هذه هي العقبه الوحيده ففي ظل غياب
نظريات اكاديميه بشان الاجابه عن تساؤلات
من قبيل ما الثوره متى بدات ومتى انتهت
وما تعريف المشاركه فيها وتباين الاراء
حياله تصبح المهمه في حكم المستحيل يضاف
الى ذلك ترسخ فكرته ان التاريخ يكتبه
المنتصر في اذهان المصريين وهو ما يثير
حساسيتهم تجاه اي محاولات رسميه لخلق
روايه تتبناها الدوله بشان اي حدث تاريخي
تزاحمت كل هذه العقبات في وجه لجنه توثيث
الثوره المصريه دافعه اياها الى مصيرها
المحتوم لتحل اللجنه نفسها بعد نحو عامين
من تاسيسها
لجنه التوثيق الثوره المصريه في 2011 وهي
لجنه عمرها قصير سنتين وحدثت فيها
اشكاليات ما ما كانت يعني ما هي درجه
صعوبه هذه المهمه لانه بدا بدات بعدها تيه
الاسئله انا قرات لك يعني تكتب عن هذا
الامر وانه الاسئله التي بدات تتولد نتيجه
وجود هذه اللجنه كانت اصعب حقيقه من انه
يتم الاجابه عليها او او يساعد على اتمام
معمل خلينا نستعرض معك هذه الاسئله او
مسيره اللجنه مسيره اللجنه انا
يعني كباحث في التاريخ كنت دائما التردد
على دار الوثائق القوميه وبقيت من ابناء
الضرب يعرفوني لما حصلت الثوره في يمكن
يوم
15 فبراير يعني بعد تنحي مبارك ايام قليله
كلفوني
بيقولوا لي احنا قدام حدث واكلنا وقتها
فاكرين ان الثوره نجحت فقلنا نوثق باب
الوثائق قالوا نوثق الثوره وخالد فهمي
يمسك من صاحب التكليف دار الوثائق الدوله
الوثائق المجلس العسكري لا ما كانش اسمه
كان مبادره من رئيس دار الوثائق وقتها
الدكتور صابر عرب مدعوم من وزاره الثقافه
وزيره الثقافه وقتها كان عماد ابو غازي
دكتور عماد ابو فضل للاجواء الثوريه كانت
الامور تسمح فقلت
انا اوافق بشرط بشرطين بشرط الاول انه اي
حاجه نطلع عليها نقدر ان احنا نجمعها
تبقى متاحه للجمهور في التو واللحظه لان
دار الوثائق بتعاني ممكن نتكلم ده
باستفاضه من عدم اتاحه مقتنياتها للجمهور
برغم ان هي مؤسسه قوميه وان في محاذير
امنيه تحول دون ذلك كتبت عن هذا الامر
كثيرا يعني كانه في شيء يراد له ان لا
يظهر الناس فانا قلت
هنجمع ماده الوثائق خطيره في 67
كل تاريخ لها يعني ده كان الشرط الاول
الشرط الثاني ان انا اشكل اللجنه
بالاستعانه مع دار الوثائق فشكلنا اللجنه
وبدانا العمل
بدانا العمل في وضع اليه للعمل هنجمع
الماده ازاي وكنت بقول ان ده حدث شعبي
وبالتالي اهم ماده بالاضافه طبعا لكلام
الساسه والمسؤولين هو شهادات الناس نفسها
وكان املي ان احنا يبقى عندنا مجموعه ضخمه
من الشهادات تمكن الباحث كمان 100 سنه ان
هو يقف على صوت المواطن المصري العادي
الذي شارك او لم يشارك في هذا الحدث
طيب هنجمع الماده ازاي وهنضرب بالباحثين
ازاي اللي هم هيسجلوا الشهادات دي وهنجمع
الشهادات في انهي مكان فده كان التحدي
الاول تاني تحدي كان قلنا نجيب الناس اللي
عايزين يدلوا بشهاداتهم في دار الوثائق
القوميه
فالامنع اعترض
ما يخشوش الدار الوثائق القوميه لانه
الدخول للضروره لازم يكون بتصريح امني ده
كان تحدي تحدي التاني اكبر تحدي هو التحدي
اللي حضرتك اشرت اليه اللي هو هي ايه
الثوره
يعني الحدث الثوري اللي احنا المفروض
بنقرى له ده ايه حدوده هل انتهى يوم ما
تنحى مبارك هل بدا بيوم المطالبه بتنحيه
مبارك ولا بدا بتنحي بن علي ولا بدا قبل
كده في مظاهرات
ضد
حرب غزه ولا ضد حرب الخليج ولا مع
الانتفاضه ولا مع انتفاضه الخبز للسبعينات
انت
ده يعني خلانا نفكر انه احنا بالحدث
الثوري ازاي نقرا له يعني هل مصر في حراك
ثوري
ايوه هو الحراك الصوتي انفجر يوم 25 يناير
انما هل ارهاصاته احنا ككلجنه مؤرخين
عايزين نعرف ايه روافده هل تمت اوجه
احتجاج ايضا شعبيه تحارب الصوره الذهنيه
اللي ذكرتها على المصريين بانه خانئين
في القرن العشرين
لانه كل رجال باشا ومحمد علي ساخصص له
النقاشه مفصلا في الحلقه الثانيه في الجزء
الثاني هل تمت اوجه لتحارب هذه الصوره عن
المصريين
يعني لما نبص على الحراك المصري في
القاهره فقط في التلاتينات والاربعينات ده
حراك ثوري دائم
طبعا جزء كبير منه ضد الاحتلال الانجليزي
وضد وجود المستعمل بس جزء اخر سلطه محليه
سلطات محليه ضد الملك ومطالبه بالدستور
طبعا مقام اتصورت 52 شالوا ده من وعينا
وطلعوا ان الجيش هو الوحيد القادر على حل
المعضله دي هي اللي هي اختزلت في المستعمر
الاجنبي انما في حراك
دائم
كان
للمطالبه بالدستور لو مش دخلنا في
الخمسينات والستينات من حيث الهبه الكبيره
طبعا ما فيش انما لو هنتكلم عن عن الحركه
العماليه
الحركه العماليه طبعا اتضربت وقت عبد
الناصر وقلصت واممت
وانا ما ببص على الحراك الشعبي واللي في
الشارع سنه
بعد الهزيمه اما نزلت يعني ده بدايه
الحركه الطلابيه المصريين الطلاب والعمال
نزلوا في مارس ونزلوا في نوفمبر سنه 68
لنفس السبب مطالبه بحوريات مطالبه
بحقوق نقابيه ماذا كانت تحمل دار الوثائق
تحدث عنها دائما ان ثمه يعني وثائق في
غايه الاهميه هذه العلاقه الغريبه عدم
السماح للاطلاع لماذا
دار الوثائق لها تاريخ
شيق انما هي هي مستودع رسمي لوثائق الدوله
اسست بقانون سنه 54 بعد 52
نواه دار الوثائق هي مجموعه وثائق
اسست في قصر عابدين في القصر الملكي
في اواخر العشرينات واوائل التلاتينات على
انه يبقى ارشيف شخصي للملك فؤاد
نواه هذه المجموعه بدورها هي الدفتر خانه
التي اسسها محمد علي سنه 1828 وكان مقرها
في القلعه فده الارشيف بتاع الدوله ارشيف
لاي مصلحه حكوميه او اي شركه بتحتفظ
بالورق القديم في تاريخ هذه المؤسسه وطبعا
كان من علامات لضج محمد علي ان هو يعمل
توثيق مش للاجيال اللاحقه بس
للبيروقراطيين
في مصر
وانشاها فقام بعد
اعلان الاستقلال امام مصر اعلنت كملكيه
دوله مستقله طابع ذات طابع ملكي سنه 23
اول حاجه عملها الملك فؤاد
هو تاسيس ارشيف للتاريخ للدوله الوليده دي
هي وطبعا كان من غرضه التاريخ لعيلته الى
انه يرى انه عيلته هي الدوله هي الدوله هي
اللي اسست الدوله الحديثه وانت عندك مشكله
مع هذا الموضوع عندي مشكله
طيب سؤال الديمقراطيه هو السؤال الرئيسي
طبعا هو السبب الذي يجمعنا هو السبب الذي
يجعلنا هو هو القضيه الاساسيه التي
يناقشها منذ اكثر من عشره اعوام وقبل ذلك
ايضا به بعشره العملات في عشره العوامل
الاخيره تبدو مستعصيه في مصر
تبدو مصلحصيه في المنطقه كلها طبعا ازمه
البلد الاكثر استقرارا حدوده وملامحه
هويته الوطنيه واضحه لا يوجد لدي اشكاليات
كبرى في في بنيته المجتمعيه وبنيته كدوله
حتى
السؤال اللي حضرتك طرحته دلوقتي في غايه
الاهميه التوصيف ده هو انا في رايي انا
متفق معك تماما ان قوه مصر الحقيقيه انها
عندها هويه واضحه عندها رؤيه ذاتيه واضحه
مشكله الاقليات في مصر قليله
كان فيه بس تاريخيا حليناها بالحديد
والنار بتكلفه باهظه انما وضعنا كدوله
كمجتمع قبل ما يبقى دوله قوي
في رايي الجزء الاخر
بيدعم استقرار مصر
هو مؤسستها المؤسسات اللي
بنيناها على مدار ال 150 200 سنه اللي
فاتوا بما فيها الجيش والشرطه جهز
الديمقراطي والصحافه والجامعات والنقابات
دي اللي بتخلي المجتمع مش بس افراد
بتخليه مؤسسات
تقدر ان هي تشيل الديمقراطيه ديمقراطيه مش
فكره بس
ديمقراطيه فكر وممارسه طيب الممارسه ايه
الممارسه مش بس انتخاب واقتراع الممارسه
هي ممارسه على المستويات دي هي في
المؤسسات دي هي في الجامعات في الصحافه في
النقابات
مشكله الديمقراطيه دلوقتي انه في مصر ان
المؤسسات دي جغرفه
وانه في اقتناع من قبل الجهاز الدوله
القوي بس كمان من قبل قطاعات كبيره من
المجتمع ان السبب
الاكبر لوحده مصر وعدم تشردمها
علقناه على مؤسسه واحده بس
اللي هو الجيش
ونسينا اهميه المؤسسات الاخرى بل بالعكس
ضحينا بالمؤسسات الاخرى
باستقلاليه الصحافه
باستقلاليه الجامعات باستقلاليه النقابات
باستقلاليه الحركه الطلابيه
باسم الحفاظ على الاستقرار وده تناقض عميق
جدا في الفكر
وعدم ادراك لتاريخ مصر
واسباب قوتها
وتقويض حقيقي
للاستقرار بالرغم من الادعاء الدائم ان ده
اللي بيحفظ استقرار البلد اشكرك على وجودك
معنا في هذه الحلقه وايضا سنستكمل النقاش
في الحلقه القادمه حول المشروع الفكري
للمؤرخ الدكتور خالد شكرا جزيلا الشكر
موصلكم مشاهدينا الكرام هذا نقاشنا
التاسيسي مع المؤرخ الدكتور خالد فهمي
والذي نتطلع من خلاله الى النقاش القادم
حول فهمه للدوله المصريه واعاده قراءته
للتاريخ المصري الحديث عبر كتبه الثلاثه
البالغه الاهميه حقيقه شكرا لكم على طيب
المتابعه دمتم بخير وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]